put the vertex of the angle at point a
so let me do that
make one of the rays go through point b
make the other ray go through one of the
other points to make an acute angle so
an acute angle is an angle less than 90
degrees so we can make one of these rays
go through point b
and then we could we have to pick where
to where to put the other ray to make it
go to one of the other points and we
have to be very careful here because we
have to look at this arc that shows
which angle the tool is actually
measuring because we might be tempted to
do something to do something like this
thinking that hey maybe this is the
angle that we're thinking about but the
tool thinks we're referring to this
outer angle right over here this larger
huge angle this angle right over here is
well over 180 degrees so we have to pay
attention to this arc to make sure that
the tool is looking at the same angle
that we are so once again we want an
acute angle so this right over here
looks like an acute angle it looks like
it is less than 90 degrees and we have
to be very careful that we go exactly
through that point so that looks about
right
this this is an acute angle because its
measure is less than 90 degrees let's do
a few more of these
make an obtuse angle using the black
points choose one of the points as the
vertex and make the rays go through the
other two points the angle should also
be less than 180 degrees
so
you could think of it several ways you
could just try to pick that point but
then when you go
when you go through these other two
points this right over here is an acute
angle this is less than 90. this is less
than 90 degrees you could do something
like this
where now when i switch the rays
the
tool is now thinking about this angle
not this kind of kind of this outer
angle right over here but this is larger
than 180 degrees so this also doesn't
apply so we really picked the wrong
point for the vertex
if you just move this out of the way and
eyeball it it looks like you get the
largest angle that's less than 180
degrees if you put the vertex right over
here
so let me do that
put the vertex right over there
and now it looks like i have constructed
a 180 degree angle and we have to be
very careful that we go right through
those points because otherwise it might
mark us
might mark us wrong so that looks pretty
good that's an obtuse angle because its
measure is
greater than 90 degrees
let's do one more of these
so another obtuse angle using the points
same general idea
same general idea so that would be an
exactly 180 degree angle
and
there we go and this is an obtuse angle
because it is greater than 90 degrees